any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
finally i'm turning the tables and using
technology
against one of the pioneers of all the
technology that we know and love and
it's
none other than dr andrew andy viterbi
who is a hero of mine
and it's such a great treat to be uh to
be with you today
andy thanks for spending some time with
us on this podcast uh from
from my house there from my office at
ucsd to wherever you may be
thank you for joining us hope i don't
disappoint you
and now we did another kind of
introduction
i haven't given your proper introduction
yet i'll do it now
uh andy verturby uh was born
uh yeah he was born uh in
you were born andrea giacomo viterbi i
think i'm saying that
you know it's become famous now in
bergamo
for all the wrong reasons
that's right uh and you're an american
electrical engineer
and businessman who co-founded qualcomm
and invented the viterbi
algorithm he has been the presidential
chair professor of electrical
engineering at usc's viterbi school of
engineering
and uh we're talking today about your
career and especially about this book
this book i'm holding up yes i'm holding
up the front cover normally
andy i say i judge books by their covers
uh and but i'm not gonna judge this book
by its cover
how did this book come about the book is
called reflections of an educator
researcher and entrepreneur and you and
i spoke about this at a synagogue
in san diego about four or three or four
years ago and uh it was a packed house
and people are just so curious about
your life and
what the wisdom that you can uh provide
but how did you come to write this
particular book it's it's not
like your your textbook is it no not
at all although i have uh a little bit
of uh
uh watered-down explanation of the
algorithm
which probably more confuses than
explains
but i did it
in a moment of some sadness but
something i wanted to leave to my
grandchildren
and my children although i point out
that
my children had lived through lived and
suffered through
a certain part of the fair part of the
narrative um
i so that was the original
and i i actually uh
bound or had bound some uh
i don't know 20 30 copies gave to
my children my grandchildren that's
about half of them
and the other half to friends uh
and close acquaintances um
this um
for some years now i've been involved
with a uh
society in new york city
which runs on a shoestring
for a very small audience
in the united states maybe a slightly
larger one in italy
are regarding italian jews
and they have in association with nyu
colombia and cuny
they put on a number of lectures by
american and italian scholars and
historians
and other
specialties um
now recently they've been doing uh zoom
uh webinars which uh
go much further afield than new york
city
and uh uh recently did one on the
uh sephardic jews of uh um
of uh salonika which was a
it's a very interesting uh
subject that based on
one family whose archives had been held
a very large broad sephardic family of
many many
branches
from about the beginning of the 19th
century
uh through the holocaust and thereafter
in any case um that's just one example
of what the
kinds of studies they uh
put on and the
they also have a book series and so
the uh the editor who's also the uh
assistant director of the primo levy
center
this uh organization that i referred to
earlier
um asked me if if he could publish this
uh
handbook which i'd given her memoir
which i'd given him
and i said sure why not and he did a
very good job on it and
made me improve a couple of sections
so we were last together last year it
was 2019
it was the 100th anniversary of the
birth of primo levy
and we did a symposium here with some
renowned chemists and
and other people uh i also pointed out
it was the uh 150th anniversary last
year of the periodic table which is
behind my back over here which is the
title of one of primo's
famous most famous uh essays
and you're related to primo can you
explain the relationship
and what was primo like as a as a person
and as a scientist
well i'm a first cousin in law that is
his wife or his late wife there
unfortunately that
generation my generation although i'm
the youngest member thereof but
most of my cousins uh my first cousins
have
passed on i have no uh siblings
so um uh
um oh yeah
so his uh his wife is my first cousin
the daughter of a distinguished
family in education and literature
her father was a published author of uh
uh a lot of he was a um
what we call high school they call
lyceum he was a lyceum professor
and uh fairly renowned but
um but the levy family i would say the
the first really famous member was primo
uh he in his um
um periodic table
periodic uh in english it's
periodic table in italian it's different
um
he uh describes his ancestors
in in the piedmont region of uh
italy and uh he's not very nice to them
he also uncovers the the
uh um dialect the
let's say the the yiddish of piedmont
which was never spoken by more than
maybe two thousand people
but uh uh ranks up there with
uh ladino and yiddish
i wasn't aware that there was another
another dialect i guess we don't we
don't lack for di
uh for dialects uh in our particular
culture
um when we when we look at your this
biography again it's called
um reflections of an educator researcher
and entrepreneur
from the cpl editions memoirs and
biography series
you have many chapters here let us start
with um
with the fact that you came here as a
refugee and you went on to
achieve these incredible heights of
success academically
as a business person entrepreneurially
and then later philanthropically what do
you
if some alien you know gets a broadcast
you know and can decode cdma and the
viterbi algorithm
and they say andy who are you what is
the core
essence of who you are how would you
answer it what sums up
who how you think about who andrew
verturby is
well i was a very fortunate man i was a
very fortunate child
and grew into a man who
was seemed to be in the right place or
in the right
[Music]
field at the right time
as a child
if i were to compare myself to other
children
of that era and they were born in
bergamo i was very lucky
in that my parents first of
all uh found a way to
enter america uh where
if they had stayed we
we would have met this the fate of uh
one of my father's closest friends the
uh
psychiatrist uh uh
joseph who um
was originally from venice and
when the racial laws that took away
all civil rights from jews
enforced in 1938 he decided just to move
back to venice because
that was his home his his origin
he knew everybody there and they were
all his friends
and in 1943 he his wife and his daughter
uh wound up in uh
a cattle car on his way to uh auschwitz
um so my father had the foresight
to find uh to seek
an exit and uh he had
it wasn't easy we did it through
switzerland through a close
colleague and friend in switzerland who
was able to pull strings with the us
console
in zurich whereas the
uh us console in naples where the uh
embassy was in well the embassy was
enrolled but the
main consulate was in naples rejected uh
his
request for a an exit visa oil
for an american visa and um
so we made it three days before the war
broke out
in uh poland uh
august 27th of 1939.
uh in that period uh public education
for children
was uh in new york and boston
were excellent and i had a good
introduction to english
after my poor exasperated teacher
who couldn't communicate with me kept
putting me
in the corner and
then we moved to boston because again to
my good fortune
my father passed the license
the medical licensing exam in
and i was able to be educated in
the boston public schools of that time
which were very good and
some of them are still good my high
school alma mater boston latin
is considered the best in the state and
possibly
of public schools because there's a lot
of preparatory schools it was a
actually a public preparatory school six
years
and uh
ranked as well or higher than the
private schools
in the area so anyway i came out of
there and was easily admitted to mit
went into the right field
electronics electrical engineering at
the time when
uh the time was ripe
mit was on the on the leading edge
partly because of the radiation lab
that had been located there during world
war
ii mostly developing radar but also
communications
and uh learned what was the
advanced electronics advanced uh
electrical and electronics theory of the
50s which is laughable by today's
standards
but uh kept with it computer science
computer wasn't even science wasn't even
considered a department
took a couple of rudimentary courses in
in
computers and uh also uh
did a co-op program which had been
active at mit for uh
most of the 20th century
you talk a lot about luck in your
autobiography
luck to escape as you just said the uh
the devastation of world war ii and the
holocaust
being able to come to america and go to
uh the schools that you were
educated at and then later yes to go to
jpl
and the time when when uh the us space
program was really ramping up for the
first time and really southern
california
what was it like i've always been
curious what was the spirit what was
kind of the
the zeitgeist like back then in terms of
entrepreneurship
creativity is this is this something
that was in the air and do you think
feel like it's something that can have a
renaissance maybe even nowadays
well in the 50s cold war
competition with the soviets and of
course sputnik was a
wake-up call uh both
for our government and also
for science because they started to pour
money in
that was the only way that science could
really
be pushed forward because
entrepreneurship
was not in the zeitgeist
there were excellent organizations
that were not military primarily
uh bell labs is particularly the one
that's recognized but so was ibm
so was general electric at that time
uh
throughout the cold war that continued
and uh entrepreneurship really started
in my recollection
probably in the 70s and then got a very
big boost
throughout the rest of the century
and the companies that i was with or
helped
found uh
initially uh were
very dependent on government funding
luckily it was a funding
non-lethal for non-lethal
devices namely uh communication
um security devices that is
anti-jam and uh
um anti-uh
and uh so that the very same technology
which generally is called spread
spectrum
person most accredited for
its initiality initialization was
hedy lamarr most of that story
is true it's a little bit embellished
but
um in any case
by the 50s it was well ingrained into
the
military communications world and
we it was
talking about entrepreneurial
um activities in the commercial world
we were probably the first to to use a
successive
successfully initially for
transportation for satellite
communication to trucks
and then later to
what is called cdma co-division multiple
access
which is one of the spread spectrum
technologies that are now used
throughout 3g 2g 3g 4g and
5g 4g was a
real breakthrough because that's how
the cell phone was connected to the
internet
how how did you realize or how did you
move from something that was academic
uh scientific or engineering and signals
and systems how did you realize that
that could have actual commercial
value or did you even because this was
decades before
it was really fully put into use if i'm
not mistaken
you know uh we transitioned seamlessly
three professors two at ucla at the time
and one at ucsd erwin jacobs
got together after a nasa
uh conference in the bay area
in 1967. it took us a while to figure
out how to found a company if
it took about a year for us to convince
ourselves that it could be done it was
worth doing
and then we got some small contracts
initially from what was then called the
naval electronics lab
it's now gone through several names spa
wars and others things like that
it's still in san diego they gave us our
first
little contract for probably
twenty thirty thousand dollars and we
were able to hire another
engineer so now we were four
one of the three founders got very
involved
in arpanet the predecessor of the
internet
and effectively dropped out we left them
some of the
worthless stock at the time a dozen
years later was
worth something and then irwin came on
full time
because we were just working one day a
week except for the uh
the uh engineer jerry heller who was the
first guy to show that the viterbi
algorithm
was feasible and was easier to implement
than most people believed
in any case we used that as a
vehicle and uh did work for
as i said the navy and then also for jpl
as they were implementing
uh their space missions to uh
uh the moon and well that was a little
later
but all their uh planetary missions
unmanned planetary missions we were
never really at a loss
because we were uh doing government
contracts
which were had
[Music]
progress payments but
uh by 1980 we were
already what we thought was a big
company we went from
three people to about um several
maybe 300 and uh
we had turned down a couple of offers
from aerospace
corporation companies like lockheed
and then along came a small conglomerate
based in boston uh that was
picking up all these little startups
most of which ultimately
collapsed but we were successful for
them
and one of the more important products
was to do
a digital television system for
uh hbo home box office
uh which uh uh was a little
uh concerned that their signal was being
stolen
and so we built them a uh
a secure digital system
and that really boosted the company
actually to some extent boosted the
parent company
and uh um
but eventually the parent company
had a palace revolution
ousted the ceo
chairman who had acquired our company
and the company started to uh
rapidly descend uh to
uh a shadow of
what it had been and uh
management was not very successful
and they remanaged us out of uh well
without going any detail it was no
longer fun
and so erwin and i quit and
three months later started qualcomm and
qualcomm
well we started it with a number of our
original leading engineers
and so to some extent we had a running
start
although we didn't have very much money
and well we had we were able to uh sell
finance for for a while then we got some
study contracts from uh
defense contractors initially in fact
the uh the um
leo the low earth orbiting satellites
uh were initiated by
based on one of our study contracts
which then led
to global star which was a great
technical achievement but a commercial
failure
along with all the others by the way
i want to talk about non-commercial
failures in terms of the marketplace but
maybe
a financial mistake that you might have
made which was not to patent
the viterbi algorithm was that a mistake
in retrospect
you talked about it in a 1999 interview
as
not really regretting it but but i
wonder you know
looking back in hindsight this is now
being used by people
you know for their own commercial
purposes why shouldn't you know
andy have gotten more of a a taste of
the of the intellectual
fruits that you had picked well to begin
with
if it had been patented it would have
been patented in 1968
when we first presented it to
a a patent attorney
told us this will never be used by any
anybody but governments it's much too
expensive and too complicated
and he was right it took about a decade
before it and probably closer to two
decades before it became
commercially valuable meanwhile
you know the industry proceeded we were
able to finally
in the late 70s put it on a single chip
and uh uh
[Music]
and and to some extent it probably
gained
um attention and ground because it was
unpatented and uh
and therefore it got into uh several
generations as far as i know it's still
in the current generation
i've been away from it for a couple of
decades so i don't
follow g5g other than what i
the advertisements i see in uh on
television which is all hype anyway
yeah which you can't avoid and that's
another question i have you know i've
heard about
4g and 3g and lte and all these things
that are going to revolutionize
and i had on peter diamandis who like
you as an mit alum
he writes all these books about you know
the future is going to be
bold and abundant because of things like
5g
uh but i i seem to remember him saying
the same thing maybe about 4g
and 3g and so my question is is it
really worth the hype
these you know can something like 5g
really revolutionize the world as you
see it
good question every g
co corresponds to one decade
and why one decade because
more players come into it and they want
their
their own thing but
there certainly have been great progress
i had the good fortune of
helping to develop 2g cdma
it was a struggle to get cdma into 2g
because the world had already
decided on a different technology a much
more conventional technology
and the europeans had run with it it's
called
uh gsm the name actually started from a
french the french
title of the working group that put it
together group special
mobile we were struggling to be
accepted in that 2g
and we were boosted by
other uh early cellular companies
into air touch and now it's called
verizon
but verizon is you know half the
users in the country and they were the
one all of these
variously named uh evolutions
uh used our technology cdma
but and uh what really boosted it was
uh the korean market the koreans uh
adopted it as their sole digital
technology
ex uh rejecting both gsm
and that and the japanese version and
in my opinion that's what really boosted
uh
samsung and other companies in korea
uh from secondary to
primary status in the industry
3g was our great success because that's
where
uh the whole world accepted it after
suing us left and right
we were attacked by ericsson
and nokia who were the european leaders
by motorola but we said we settled with
everybody
favorably at the end of the
90s i turned 65 and i retired
i'd had my fun however a
very small company that was an offshoot
from bell labs
came and asked me to join their board
and be on their advisory committee
and they were the ones who really um
boosted the next technology 4g
and had the foresight
to design it in a way that it was
particularly
adapt adapted for the internet
by uh uh
minimizing the lag times uh
which are so disturbing
uh so i had the very good fortune to be
part of that
it wasn't nearly the financial success
that qualcomm had been but it was a very
satisfying
role to be kind of a uh
godfather to that one it's called
flareon by the way
it was bought by qualcomm to which i
give
my colleagues credit then
5g started in the 2010s
as i said it it had to wait
all these things are always under
development
starting at least five years prior to
the decade but
the first uh tentative uh
implementations are uh put out in uh
in the zero uh year 20
2000 2010 2020 um
i i won't go into the details of 2020
because
it's only what i read in the papers
but it it exploits a a very
high frequency band and
it therefore uses a small
antenna but it has fairly low range so
you have to have very many
which applies very well for cities but
not so well
for rural areas so that's all you know
so i had the good luck of spending most
of my career
in an industry that was growing faster
than anything else in
the amphibious industry another example
of
luck triumphing um i want to ask you a
little bit more about commercialization
but maybe not
in the way that we were just talking
about it
and that's to say the value of basic
research in science and engineering
theoretical research and
and even you know basic research like i
do in cosmology
which as you know the cosmic microwave
background radiation that i study
uh was really discovered at bell
laboratories which
you know exists and you can go and visit
the you know the seven meter horn
antenna there in homedale and i know
you've had a lot of
interaction with bell laboratories and
we'll talk about that maybe later but
what i want and then subsequently bell
labs went on i believe to invent one of
the first cell phones and
and uh and and many other patents and
and so forth
but really wasn't able to survive as a
you know non-commercial pure research
based facility
and now is owned by nokia and they still
call it bell labs but that's just for
historical uh you know attribution i
suppose
but you know i've often heard things
decrying how poor the funding
is in basic mathematics in basic science
that is science without a profit or
engineering motive
and yet we always want our kids and our
grandkids etc to go into stem fields
and so i'm wondering is there a way have
you thought of a way
that we could use the you know kind of
inventions that come out of basic
research like viterbi algorithm enabling
cdma and enabling
very high performance uh mobile
communications
can we use that to generate um
not i don't say wealth or income but to
generate resources financial resources
for theoretical physicists and
cosmologists and and mathematicians to
benefit from so that this virtuous cycle
can continue
i mean coming out of industry rather
than from government
maybe both i mean the government you
know uh has
is not the only you know kind of uh
supplier of research funding but they
sure do benefit tremendously they
benefited from cdma they benefited
from the viterbi algorithm and you
didn't uh patent it so they could do
whatever they want
but uh but they don't seem to feed that
back into
basic that is you know uh what what
nobel laureate sheldon glashow called on
my program useless research
you know the fundamental particles of
nature aren't going to speed up our
internet
but i think it's part of what drives us
as human beings so
is there a way we can commercialize you
know utilize the commercial
uh benefits of email you know attacks on
every you guys used to own eudora
that was one of your products and i
remember correctly
which i used for a long time uh what
about taxing each email and then
funneling some of that money back into
mathematics
crazy idea but what do you think about
ways to to
utilize the the intellectual property
uh to benefit basic research
well it's a it's a good idea it probably
can't be done
let me just pick up on some of the
things you said yes
bell labs
bill labs today is not what it was okay
when judge green broke up at t he
uh he
significantly demolished
degraded the value of the of their
of the jewel of the uh
att system uh and then
att ultimately was grabbed by the
most aggressive of the baby bells but
uh they had quite a run uh
all of well many fields including the
ones i've
been most interested in really got their
start at bell labs
uh you were talking about uh
uh radio astronomy uh and you will know
that arnold pensius
uh he was very lucky where you were not
and he got the nobel prize interestingly
a bell lab scientist who i knew well has
passed on
fairly young actually told me that he
didn't understand the first thing about
information theory
that he had been since arno was the vice
president of research i think
my friend had uh briefed him
a number of times on what was called the
math lab
or the mathematical uh
application slap and uh
didn't didn't get his message through
very well
but uh bell labs is uh was was a unique
organization the problem is
for the corporations
even the largest ones i would give
microsoft a little more credit than the
others
i've heard bill gates talk about
uh how their research labs and the
people he has in them
uh i google has some very smart guys
and gals but i'm not sure that they have
the same
uh interest in science
they may they certainly started out with
some
good applied mathematicians launching it
uh paige and bryn
but certainly the smaller companies and
i
among them i would include
qualcomm have the disadvantage of having
shareholders and
they won't look beyond the next fiscal
year
and so that's the problem with the
industry the problem with
government is there is greed
and ignorance in congress and the
president
now we may improve on that
uh i made some comments towards the end
of the memoir
about capitalism and socialism uh i know
it's a dirty word
it isn't to me but uh
it is uh people seem to get scared by it
but as long as this remains a democracy
and is
reasonably well governed as as is the
case in
much of western europe
the uk still germany france
it it works they all have better
more efficient health systems than we do
even though in fact well we but but our
scientists are still as
still the best in the world for a simple
reason they attract people
they attract the best of the
cream of the crop from all over from
asia from europe
from africa but
hopefully we can get back to that uh
way of doing things we've certainly lost
our
a lot of uh respect in the
last four years do you think that you
know actually
literally applying attacks or you know
physicists
played a huge role in the invention uh
and darpa
et cetera in the invention of uh
of you know email and http proto ftp
protocols
and also obviously the world wide web at
cern was invented at cern
to large extent uh but would would it
not
impede progress to say have some kind of
attacks i mean do you think there'd be
less creativity had had or less
development
let's say you would you did patent it um
and you made you know
the they did pay for it the government
would have paid for it
it was a small amount of money to them
uh would that have impeded like will we
only be on 2g now
uh in other words does does monetizing
be like taxation
does that ultimately impede progress
well in my opinion and it's
strictly my opinion if debatable
uh i believe that
as long as we were in a uh
existential uh struggle with
uh eastern europe with russia
with the soviet union uh we poured a lot
of money into
uh into
[Music]
research uh
a lot of it wasted
but we did great things in space and
aeronautics
and even more important in
communication tying together
for better and sometimes for worse our
nation
and the world
with the end of the cold war we
much curtailed that
industry or private enterprise more
likely
more properly uh was
uh is a great uh
[Music]
um
because it incentivizes people
incentivizes
mostly for
uh for wealth
but also in the
technological fields and that includes
of course all the biological fields
it also incentivizes people to
to do things that are have never been
done before
uh independent of whether they're uh
profitable or not
and you get better people doing that
uh not that you know not that in the
cold war we didn't have very good people
but uh as
as that whole project
wound down the people that are
attracted to government work
are not quite the same level
the ones who are more are either
in it for science and culture
and stay at universities or else they
uh they go to industry and and try to
make the best of products
so it's a balancing act uh are we
and and and it's a pendulum that swings
between creativity and uh in action
[Music]
absolutely okay well we've got a few
more
minutes left and i have a few more
questions so it should work out pretty
well
i want to ask you you may have heard
recently of
the uh possible detection
of a techno signature which is to say
a carrier wave signal coming from
a particu a star system known as proxima
centauri b and proxima centauri proxima
means as you know from
your latin upbringing uh with the
romance language uh it means nearest
so so proximus and jury is our nearest
celestial neighbor
and it seems as if there's a roughly one
gigahertz
uh tone coming from that particular
direction that particular star system
only about four light years away
and that has been declaimed by a team
called the breakthrough um listen
listen meaning like ear listen uh
program up at uc berkeley i've got many
friends that work up there
and loosely affiliated with uh with the
allen telescope array which is funded in
part by franklin antonio
who is one of your uh friends and and co
uh
collaborators and and link a bit and
qualcomm etc
but we've detected apparently some
signal i talked to a
a a a scientist about this recently jill
tarter
who is the inspiration for the character
and
carl sagan's contact movie ellie arroway
but anyway
what do you make about this what do you
think that extraterrestrials exist first
of all andy and second of all
uh would they how would you communicate
how would you tell the proximans
you know what would you tell them about
about us and how would you do so
well they uh there's been a program
to look to try to find extraterrestrials
for at least 60 years it was called the
sea tie
i don't recall what the acronym stood
for but
i was started at stanford in their uh
antenna farm in fact i was invited to
that
to participate but i had just gotten to
ucla
and uh just that was bracewell was that
with bracewell or
was that uh was it was that with a
professor bracewell
at stanford or whoever was that's right
yes
and uh in fact my
younger colleague jim memorial worked
there for quite
a number of years uh while still being
at uc
at ucla um
so yes uh
it's worth doing uh franklin is a very
inter
intelligent and very interesting fellow
uh
whether it well
uh should i put odds on it
ten to the minus six that's being
generous
yeah i i tend to also uh
what was it called i the
the survey that looked for planets
that had similar characteristics to the
earth yeah there's a bunch of surveys
one is called kepler one is called tess
these are uh these are surveys in space
that are looking for either the dimming
of a planet by a star
by a dimming of by of a star by a planet
uh transit or perturbations to its orbit
and we've detected thousands of planets
some even earth-like very earth-like
planets around
very sun-like stars and yet um
i'm curious why do you think the
probability for the existence of not not
just like a slime mold
but but intelligent so seti stands for c
ties you say
stands for uh either communicating with
extraterrestrial intelligence
or searching for extraterrestrial
intelligence but um
why do you think the odds are so low
actually if it's one in a million and
there's 10 to the 20th stars
that means that there's it could be a
lot but i assume you mean the overall
odds of any technological life is
extremely low why do you feel that way i
mean the percentage is one in a million
yeah if you say one on a million stars
you're talking about literally
you know a billion a million stars in
our in our own galaxy potentially
yeah and it may be approaching infinity
although mathematicians
right uh so uh
i i really had a loss
to comment on that uh it's certainly
well with
the kinds of project programs like
the uh finding the black holes
and won another nobel prize more for i
guess
administration than for science but
uh that that was so remarkable that you
cannot
exclude anything from happening
uh but uh you know
given our uh very limited imagination
talking about myself but human beings
always cook up something that makes
sense to them and makes no sense
otherwise who knows what that
that um other life if there is other
life
who knows what it's like it's not little
green men
they don't look like us
intelligence only if you can if you
believe in artificial intelligence
uh not that i believe that we're going
to be taken over
by cyclops
but um then anything is possible
yeah i do uh i do always note that i'm
still looking for
signs of of terrestrial intelligence
uh that occupies a lot of my time well
andy i'm we're coming to the end i do
want to ask you the questions that i ask
all of my
honored and treasured guests who do come
on the
into the impossible podcast which is
named after
one of uh sir arthur c clarke's famous
three laws we'll get to that in a second
did you ever know sir arthur
or meet arthur not in person but i think
i was on a call
with him through the marconi society
ah some years some decades ago
very nice so i i usually ask my guests
um
hearkening back to the conversation we
had at the synagogue not too long ago
what they would put in an ethical will
so
not a material will but in judaism we
have this concept called the
zava ah which means ethical will and it
sort of hearkens back to what
moses does in the book of deuteronomy
where he kind of gives all these
imprecations and and threats and very
few
like uh blessings seem to come out of it
but uh but there's sort of
a lot of warnings and i wonder uh what
would you put in
in your ethical will not your material
will uh but but something to leave to
your children of which you know uh
you you you have many and grandchildren
but um
uh but actually to your ideological
children like me
people that look to you as a role model
what would you put out there
as inspiration as wisdom in an ethical
will
well i actually touch on that briefly
in the i think in my preface and
uh what i uh what i
say there is that if you find something
that you enjoy
uh if you're so lucky as to
actually be turned on by your uh
the choice the career of choice and the
kinds of
things and projects and books you write
or
plays you uh you
create uh or uh scientific activities
uh then uh that's
one of the real joys of life you
effectively you're not working a day of
your life you're spending it all
having fun of course there's also family
which brings
a a higher level of
satisfaction uh if things
if you're successful or if you're lucky
it's always
i always come back to that i married a
woman who was
extraordinary and much of
what my grandchild my kids and my
grandchildren
are doing is and the way they're living
their lives
is a lot of it due to her and
i finished that memoir just before she
passed i have no idea that
i wouldn't be able to share it with her
yeah yeah she was uh she was a real
treasure not just for
for san diego i had the honor and
blessing to meet her
several occasions uh ever since i came
here in 2004 and and she was as gracious
and
and delightful a human being we miss her
terribly too
and we're so glad that you have shared
your wisdom with us
i want to continue with that and also
connect to
sir arthur c clarke uh by evoking
the memory of a movie called 2001 a
space odyssey did you ever see that andy
um some parts of it i can also fall
asleep on it
i do that yeah the opening scene has
these ape-like creatures
uh in africa and they encounter this
monolith this huge black
obelisk or whatever it is we don't know
what it is really but it's it's really
sort of a time capsule placed by an
ancient alien civilization
to kind of wake i was still awake to see
that yeah that well that's the opening
credit so
i don't give you much credit for staying
awake for that but but i i don't fault
you for falling asleep
i think i i closed my eyes the first
time i saw it because i was scared but
anyway
um thinking about that a time capsule
the notion of a time capsule
has always been appealing to people
throughout history and actually i talked
to carl sagan's
widow her name is anne druyan and i
asked her what would you put on a
billion year long
time capsule that would last for a
billion years and she said i did that
when the voyager satellite was launched
in uh
in the 70s or 80s or early 70s she had
her brain waves recorded by carl sagan
who made this golden
disc and it had music and had all sorts
of other things
and that went into the outer reaches of
our solar system and is now
in interstellar space i want to ask you
and i think i might know what you might
put on it
but what aspect um as richard feynman
the famous nobel laureate said
if in some cataclysm all scientific
knowledge was destroyed
and only one sentence could be passed on
to the next generation
of creatures what statement would
contain the most information
in the fewest words and he said i
believe it is the atomic hypothesis that
all things are made of atoms
i want to ask you andy what one thing
would you most want to put on a monolith
to last for a
billion years that would encapsulate you
or what you've learned or
the grandeur of of humankind
well quantum mechanics
that works but nobody really understands
why
some say that about the viterbi
algorithm that's trivial
very good okay the last question i asked
goes the opposite direction we've gone
into the future
with a time capsule and with your
ethical will um now i want to ask you
backwards i want to ask you in terms of
advice to your former self
what would you what would you say once
seemed impossible to a young
20 30 year old andy viterby but now
seems eminently feasible because you had
the courage
to go into the impossible i guess i
would say
communicating uh in real time
worldwide looks like you just got sounds
like you just got a message from
some distant planet on on your device
over there
so that seemed impossible well that
makes a lot of sense it certainly seems
magical to me that
while you and i are in the same town but
but i talked to people
i talked to a woman from egypt not too
long ago
and it was just incredible that we could
be talking about
my book she's a devout muslim i'm a
devout
jew and we can have a conversation
instantaneously at the speed of light
and a large part of it
is thanks to you oh i can't resist andy
i'm sorry if you have one more minute
you've won a tremendous number of
accolades and awards
but i don't want to just focus on that i
want to ask you a question
um let me just let me just get these
back so you've we've won the following
awards and i don't want to talk about
the awards as you know
my feelings about awards etc but you've
won the alexander graham bell prize
the marconi medal the claude shannon
award
the james clerk maxwell medal and the
john fritz medal which i don't know much
about but of
all those people of all those people
maxwell
uh shannon marconi graham bell
who would you most like to meet to
explain the viterbi algorithm too
well first of all it wouldn't be shannon
because he would look at it and say
that's trivial it was clearly in one of
my papers
he was a very very tim very shy
individual
but uh but uh he's uh
uh no i would be uh i have met shannon
and i'd be embarrassed
uh i would uh i would
uh love to meet uh
james clark maxwell yeah he
pushed well he's a mathematician
basically
uh more of a theorist than a practical
uh uh hurts um heinrich hertz had done
the experiment but he didn't understand
a
why and b that it would ever be
practical he
said that specifically i know james
clark maxwell really
and it wasn't just electromagnetics he
did a lot of other things
and uh i think he was the greatest
scientist of the 19th century
20th century you've got you've got a lot
of candidates
einstein of course but feynman and
uh and many others and shannon
did you overlap with feynman when you
were in caltech or jpl
he was oh he was at caltech i was just
working at the laboratory
and uh but one of my closest friends
saul galum was very close to so it's
a uh one number what do you call it
one one uh step away like the uh
one degree of separation right
well andy i want to thank you so much uh
you're really a legend and you're one of
my heroes i love talking to you because
you're not only
a phenomenal scientist you are um
you're a philanthropist and you're an
incredible father grandfather
maybe great grandfather i don't know
thank you too many compliments but thank
you very much
and uh i will say that you handle it
very well
because i was a little bit uh i won't
say i was worried but i was a little
uncertain uh doing this because i have
trouble with words as you
probably have noticed i can't remember
words and
even terms that i used to know very well
and that's
something that's happening in my brain
but i'm carrying on nevertheless
i'm i'm not as creative but i still
enjoy
uh mathematics
and you handle it well thank you well i
just love talking to you
i love doing events with you we've done
this is our third event together maybe
we'll go on the road in 2021
and uh do some stadium stadium tours
maybe a call the old qualcomm stadium
andy have a blessed uh 2021 uh we
send my bestie to your your children and
your grandchildren and i hope that we
can meet again maybe in person
in 2021.
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
you